hello everyone my name is reto meier and
welcome to this week in Android
development for october 8 2012 comments
from last week's episode suggest that my
broad Australian accent becomes entirely
impenetrable at the speed at which I've
been delivering this week in Android
updates those of you who did understand
me are probably jealous of those who
couldn't nonetheless and Google were all
about making information universally
accessible so this week's news has been
post processed so that you can watch it
play back at half speed you're welcome
you also told us that our new studio
made many of you uncomfortably aware of
the emptiness of the human condition the
transient insignificance of our
momentary human existence we briefly
considered removing the backup entirely
but it was decided that revealing the
constructs within the Googleplex might
be in violation of our employee NDA
ultimately return to our original
projection which makes it more readily
believable that we are projections are
ruling artificial intelligence for
humans represent little more than a
cheap source of energy rest assured this
will be the sixth time we've rebuilt us
to do simulation and we've become
exceedingly efficient at it in other
Android news Roman and Nick made over
travel booking and planning apps
kayaking trip advisor on Android design
in action both apps have been updated
with glamorous new tablet layouts
perfect for planning your vacation from
the comfort of your couch on Thursday
the developers of Chi app Hipmunk and
weld scope webcams joined us in person
and over hang out to inform us that
they've already thought of everything we
said we'll have an update coming out in
the next couple of weeks that fixes
everything like musician in Catdaddy
Jackson galaxy will be dropping by our
patients a little later to see how
they're doing on Friday dynamic duo
kokhim and Dan Galpin were reunited for
a jaundiced episode of the Friday games
review earlier last Friday the wheels
well and truly fell off the well-oiled
machine that is the app clinic we spend
some time trying to bug the issue before
we look through our surveillance footage
and manage to diagnose the likely source
of the problem we've got a fix in place
so don't worry we'll be back this friday
to review video player apps and we're
using the extra time to dig a little
deeper into the code that makes these
app stick with no app clinic patients to
rebuild in their own image you might be
worried that Nick and Roman won't be
dispensing their own brand of design
wisdom next Tuesday fear not we're
declaring this tablet week so tune in as
we attempt to fuse Nick and Roman into a
single conjoined entity join the
creature we've dubbed Neiman on
Tuesday as it celebrates table week by
sharing some essential tablet design
tips then on Thursday we're inviting
some successful tablet developers to
join us over hang out to share their
tablet development challenges and
successes help make every week tablet
week we've also released a set of tablet
quality guidelines to help you build
apps that delight and intrigue the
growing number of Android tablet users
dan & Co we're back next Friday for
another installment of the Friday games
review and of course you can tune in to
our developer office hours on Wednesday
live from Downton Abbey mountain view
Sydney and Brazil for this week's us
office hours we're trying something new
we're taking pre reported video
questions so record yourself asking a
question and send the video to our
Google+ page at plus android developers
as always you can find all of last
week's shows in the schedule for this
week at Google developers live that's
developers.google.com / live / android
you can also meet some of our developer
advocates live in the flesh when Nick
butcher presents modern Android UI is a
def vest bill in this weekend the
thirteenth and fourteenth of October
from the fully operational sea-based
space station this week in Android
documentation we've expanded the Android
accessory protocol docks which can now
be found on source android com of also
updated the dialogues guide to include
details for using dialogue fragments and
finally we have a new addition to
Android training with the new class
detailing how to save data within your
apps remember persisting user data isn't
just a good idea it's best practice in
ARP releases and updates this week we
saw the release of the tomtom navigation
sweet new release from quicken loans my
Quicken Loans mobile and Showtime
anytime now lets you watch your favorite
show time shows without your telly box
that includes Dexter whose companion app
will let you stay one step ahead of our
favorite psychotic serial killer that's
all for this week in Android development
we look forward to you joining us for
our many live shows this week and
remember no shoes no shirt and I still
get service my name is reto Meier thanks
for watching